yeah it's crazy no you're not on drugs
it's it's cursors yeah i mean i know
it's crazy
all right guys i know there's a lot of
cursors but just bear with me
yeah my computer is hacked
[Music]
kramnik you know when i got the pairings
it was
a um just a surreal moment now i had
played kramnik in 2014
uh and i played him in the london chess
classic rapid i played him in a rapid
tournament in the final round
and i drew with the white pieces in
berlin so i i drew him in a rapid game
this was my first classical game against
him in qatar masters this was
the strongest open tournament ever held
magnus played in the 2016 edition
i also played there uh and when i got
the pairings the night before i was like
holy frickin smokes
and i posted on facebook and i could
even
trace that facebook post i posted
something like i was i was at that
moment a freshman in stanford i was like
of all the essays i wrote
i'm pretty sure playing kramnik with
black is going to be harder
and not only was i playing kramnik i was
playing him with black
and i was like okay i'm going to try my
best
hunker down he comes to the board it's a
surreal experience to just have him
sit at the board he's very intimidating
kramnik is tall
he he projects confidence he's
you know there's something about these
guys you look at them from a distance
you're like okay they're just normal
people
but when kramnik comes to the board he
sits down i'm like
okay like this guy is serious i need to
play serious chess
and your hands just start shaking so
kramnik starts with the ready knight
f3d5 we transpose
into a grunfeld which i i had dabbled
with i'm mostly a king's indian player
but i also play the grunfeld sometimes
um especially in classical chess bishop
g7 and now kramnik goes d4
so if white castles he allows e5 and
this is the reverse perk
and the reverse perk is just it's i play
this with white but it's not
dangerous for black you can just go
knight c6 and then this is totally fine
for black
so kramnik is not about that stuff he
goes
uh for this sort of more topical d4 and
we get the symmetrical grunfeld
fianchetto c4
and i play d take c4 the other move here
is
c6 just defending the pawn there is a
ton of theory here
and i will not get into it right now uh
there's just a ton of theory here
in terms of popularity um just so you
guys know
c6 5000 games c d takes the for 4 000
games
so both moves are very popular and
kramnik goes
knight to a3 essentially trying to
recover the pawn this is theory now i go
c3
and the move c3 this is a very typical
idea in these positions
essentially the logic behind this is i'm
going to lose the pawn anyway
so i might as well give it up for
something i might as well ruin white's
pawn structure a little bit again i
don't want to get into this too much
um what is the difference between this
is kind of like a catalan right
and now i go c5 contesting the center a
very typical grunfell desk move
of course uh taking the pawn would be a
terrible idea because look at what white
creates here i mean black and go 94
this is just horrible and um
kramnik goes 95 this is all theory
knight c6 sacrifices upon
still all fairy and the point of the
sacrifice without getting too deep
is that if black if white takes on c6
and this idea actually exists
uh in a bunch of different lines black
develops with tempo bishop h3
and if you look at white's pieces
they're actually very awkward
so this is this is a big initiative that
black develops here
people don't really play like this
anymore and kramnik goes knight a to c4
which is the main move
and here's the funny thing i go knight
t5 this is all theory takes takes
this position was familiar to me and the
only move that was familiar to me
was bishop b2 which at the time this
game was played 2015.
it sounds weird to say that phrase at
the time this game was played but
times have really changed in five years
i mean that's crazy to say but it's true
bishop b2 was back then the main move
kramnik
after a one minute think plays the move
bishop d2
and pardon my french but when he played
this move
i was like oh [ __ ] because
two things came through my mind the
first was
i don't know this move kramnik has just
made a move that i don't know
that's not good second thing that came
through my mind
wait a minute i can take his pawn this
is probably some sort of crazy
preparation
kramnik is playing crazy preparation
against me with the white pieces i am
screwed
and essentially that was exactly the
truth of the matter
the funny thing is in the post-game
interview which kramnik gave i can show
you guys but it's not that interesting
he essentially said something like okay
no i mean okay i
i looked a little bit that's an old
analysis i mean okay my seconds had
prepared for me this move okay five
years ago i mean i don't know really
very much about it i only studied it for
like four weeks
for daniel okay so this was some old
analysis that his team had prepared for
him
which he sort of uncourt uh at this game
which i was like all right
all right vlad all right vlad well i
don't have a goddamn team all right
i know you only looked at this for five
minutes but great
now was this a novelty this was not
technically a novelty it was
played in 2008 it was played a couple of
times in fact
before my game by players who were not
very famous
uh kramnik was the first well-known
player to play this
and here's the hilarious thing after
kremnic
this move was repeated later in the same
tournament by david howell 2700 gm from
england
it was repeated in 2016 and 17 by
2 700 plus rated players so he literally
sets
trends kramnik plays something all of
these gm's who already play this opening
they freaking turn their heads and they
repeat his lines i mean that is
essentially the power of being someone
like kramnik you get to set the tone
for for what is played okay
so let's unpack exactly why taking the
pawn is a bad idea here and this has
happened a couple of times the move is
actually just rook c1
and the idea if i can explain it in
simple terms there's two ideas
first look at this bishop we actually
transpose into a game that was played in
1973.
if his bishop is undefended which means
white has a bunch of discovered attacks
on the cards number two this pawn on c6
is very weak
and if white picks it off like this
don't forget about this g2 bishop that
could
really strike uh deeply into black's
position so this is actually super
dangerous for black
the computer let's see what the computer
says the computer says
that black is slightly worse yeah so
this is actually very high quality
analysis
and black actually is is much worse here
he and he's got to be very careful just
not to be losing
it's just hard to find a move if you
just drop the bishop back for example
then after knight a5 it's already plus
minus you have to give this up
well and this is just totally nasty with
that bishop operating on contested
so i i detected all of this and i
actually played a reasonable move here
i played a reasonable move i played
bishop
a6 which later came to be the known as
the main move
uh so i really tried this game and
kramnik goes knight to e5
and okay so i can take the knight but i
really don't want to do that because
that would be
mean giving up my fiance bishop and look
at
these holes around the king so i
wouldn't want to do that unless there
was a good reason
so i went queen d6 defending defending
the d6 pawn and potentially putting
pressure on the knight
so i think that the best move in this
position was later determined to be
queen to c7
um this is a line that has happened
several times since then
and i think you're supposed to now take
the knight black has a path to equality
which is very narrow
uh which i of course was not aware of at
the time it's a computer-ish line i
don't want to look at it
i went queen d6 and kramniko's rookie
one and this is just so
deep typical kramnik type of chest why
does he go rookie one well he unpins the
pawn
okay and so the idea is if i take on e5
twice
then he's got several things at his
disposal
he no longer has to worry about
defending the pawn so his move here
would have been queen to c1
okay essentially defending this pawn
preparing c4 bishop c3 and preparing
stuff like bishop h6
so rookie one is an effective
prophylactic move okay
just liberating the queen from the
responsibility of defending it too one
advice
that i have for you guys is the queen
should not be doing menial tasks on the
chessboard if you find
that your queen is tied down to a pawn
that's
not usually a good thing it's sometimes
worthwhile to hand off responsibility
to a piece of lesser value such as the
rook or the bishop so that the queen
could be doing
bigger and greater things if that makes
sense this is not a dogma
but it's just an idea hope hopefully
this this helps you guys at least a
little bit
now in this position i thought for like
20 minutes i took the pawn
in this position i thought for like 20
minutes i couldn't decide do i take the
night do i not
and i finally decided to take the knight
which was actually a very reasonable
decision i simply win a pawn and in
return kramnik gets
uh he gets rid of my fiance bishop which
obviously is a very serious positional
gain for white
and um the question now becomes well
who's better here does white have enough
compensation for the pawn
the answer is yes he has not only enough
compensation black is the one who's got
to be very careful here
this has happened four times since my
game
and actually according to the computer
well
it's hard for black to even equalize the
move rook ada
is the actual equalizing move according
to my analysis
and the idea is essentially to prepare c
takes d4
followed by c5 undermining the knight
but to find
all of this in a classical game over the
board would be really hard
um and akash says exactly what i thought
okay
exactly what i was thinking which is
that the dark squared weaknesses i
realized that i was giving up my bishop
but i didn't think that okay my king was
gonna get under such a big attack
he doesn't have any pieces on the king
side okay
and i didn't fully appreciate
how many ideas white in fact does happen
what kramnik does the next 20 moves
is going to be freaking incredible okay
so just buckle up and i'm going to try
my best to explain his moves
he starts with rook c1 very
understandable he just brings his rook
in
and he attacks c6 to which i respond
rook after d8
uh which i think is actually a very good
move and this i think is a novelty yeah
so there was one other game
that went rook fc i didn't want to tie
my rook down to the defense of the pawn
so what is my idea i was really hoping
that kramnik would take
and i had calculated a really nice line
here let me try to remember what it was
there was some sort of drawish line here
that went i think bishop b7
i guess i remember and if rook c1
then there was some like knight c3
related idea or maybe i just go rook b8
and essentially it's actually good for
me that the pawn is gone because now my
own bishop is
contesting the long diagonal
okay so there was some reason
that taking is bad i again i don't want
to delve too deeply into these
technicalities
kramnik goes queen to c2 he gets his sp
he gets his queen out of the x-ray
and i go rook a to c8 now if i had gone
bishop b5
he can simply chase the bishop away with
a4 so unfortunately the bishop doesn't
hold on i go rook c8 i defend the pawn
yeah there is a knight e3 idea yeah yeah
oh that was the idea actually i think
yes that's exactly right chess lover
beautiful that was my idea
93 takes bishop takes g2
and now queen d5 picks off the bishop
and i'm actually better here because of
his ruined pawn structure
so i actually played a really really
good game and i'm proud of the way that
i played kramnik just played an
incredible game
so i defend the pawn kramnik ghost queen
to c5 tightening
the pressure he's putting his queen here
he's he's attacking a7
and he's creating a threat against
black's queen what is actually white's
threat here
if it were white to move what would he
do specifically and hint
he is not going to take on a seven what
is he going to do
man i could do this all day
we still got how many viewers do we have
just because i don't have chat open
in the way that i normally do we have
7 56 at 5 00 a.m incredible so big shout
out
before i proceed to the analysis
everybody who supports
i hope you guys are enjoying it's
different from what i normally do
but i i mean i hope that people are
having a good time i certainly am
and once again i appreciate uh people
participating and
uh just it's an awesome community so
thank you guys
let's proceed um he's threatening e4
he's threatening e4 and he's going to
win the he's going to win the night
because i can't move the night the
queen's uninvented so i go queen to d6
and again
i came up with what i think is a really
nice idea
if he takes on a7 i go c5 i trap his
queen
i'm threatening rook c7 to win the queen
and if he takes my knight i will take
his bishop
if he takes my bishop i take his bishop
and it's a draw i mean we may allow it
to draw
and drawing kramnik with black not the
worst thing in the world
so i was hoping he would do this spoiler
alert kramnik doesn't do it he goes
queen a5
so what's instructive about the way he
plays here is he doesn't mind being down
a pawn
he just he goes for the long term
initiative he doesn't
try to win the pawn immediately thank
you bingtown california thank you so
much for the 500 bits keeping me going
with some energy
always appreciate it and uh he's
attacking bishop and if i move my bishop
back well then he's going to take the
pawn because now he's attacking the
bishop
as well so i go c5 extending the defense
on the bishop if he takes my knight
again
what really helps me here is the fact
that his bishop is unprotected
so he takes mine i take his again we
have a mass
petering out and we have a draw so
bishop h3 is what kramnik does here a
very very good move so let me try to
explain
this move 123 from jacob thank you the
move bishop h3
accomplishes a couple of things it it
unfiam ketos the bishop which may
make it seem very unnatural right you
don't normally don't want to leave g2
with the bishop
but he's unsettling my position right
he's sort of
forcing a concession of some sort
because whatever i do i'm going to
weaken my position if i move the rook
away i'm going to give up c5 i didn't
want to give up c5
if i move my rook to c7 you guys can
probably see that this creates some very
unwelcome tension
and he can actually probably just go e4
and then go bishop f4 and
stuff like that i mean i didn't want to
allow it if i go rook c6 then the queen
is overloaded the queen is tasked now
with defending the rook
didn't want to do that either um so i go
e6
but so why not rook c6 maybe i should
have gone rook c6
um why specifically i guess is the
question
i think i didn't want to allow something
like rook c to d1 and now
bishop f4 becomes a big threat because
the queen
is going to have to be tied down to the
defense of the rook thank you jacobski
21 for the tier 1 appreciate it
and so i go e6 which is the same move in
spear f5 would be two weakening okay
five
would create what's called a hook on the
king side which he would exploit with
the movie for
so i play e6 which also weakens what
exactly does this weaken guys
and how does white exploit this week as
kramnik's next move exploits
directly the weakness created by the
movie six
and this is what makes this play so
aesthetically pleasing every single move
builds on top of the previous one
it weakens f6 how does white exploit f6
that's exactly right it weakens f6 okay
mushroom
i'm feeling generous either participate
yep all right
dark squares how does he exploit it
bishop g5 is exactly right
attacking the rook contesting the square
and if i go f6 we saw this in my game
against ortiz kramnik counter strikes
with e4
i didn't do this if the knight moves
bishop f6
if i take he takes and my position just
collapses
because e6 is going to fall with check
and everything here just collapses so i
can't do that
okay i move my rook away fine
but now kramnik continues to put
pressure he goes oops he goes rook cd1
and again it creates a threat this time
the threat is to play e4
and exploit the pin so i'm like damn
where do i go because if i go queen b6
trying to trade queens this is my
initial intention
i didn't like this even though this is a
very tempting move
and the reason i didn't like this i
think
is because after queen a3 essentially
the knight is the only piece now
defending f6 right
and if he goes e4 do you guys see a
potential lobster pins are made in the
works
so look at this e4 bishop f6
and then queen e3 and queen h6 and he's
got a lobster pincermate
and all of a sudden do you guys remember
when i took his knight and i was like ah
look at my king is perfectly safe
what's up queen my king is perfectly
safe nothing's happening
all of a sudden we're talking lobster
pins are made 10 moves later such as the
power of kramnik
okay so i don't do that i go queen e5
another good move
so i find a way to get the bishop out of
g5
because if he takes my bishop i take his
we've seen that as a theme
and he has no way to defend this bishop
with tempo if he goes f4 that weakens
his own king i go queen e3 check
and so kramnik and this is another thing
that makes him amazing is he's able to
be again we talked about flexibility
white's already better and i
beat back the first wave of attack but
that doesn't mean he doesn't mount a
second one he goes bishop d2
now this seems like a concession it
seems that kramnik is admitting
the failure of his strategy but he's
actually not he's just gearing up for
the second stage of the attack
so why is it why is the bishop on d2
well notice first of all that he's now
actually attacking my bishop my bishop
doesn't have that many good squares if i
go to b7 he can still take on a7
uh if i take on e2 well this is just
suicide after bishop f1
clearly and there's just no good squares
there's no good way to defend the bishop
either and his bishop
is preparing to potentially reroute to
c3
and if it reroutes to c3 it has exactly
the same effect that it would have on f6
it's just x-raying sizzling on that
diagonal and it's going to create mating
ideas i didn't like that
so i go queen to h5 i try to
counter-attack again the other bishop
and create an attack on the e-2 pawn
so if he drops it back to its fiance
square i take on e2 this time i can do
this
and then i bring my own bishop on f3 but
what does kramnik do
and this is like such a typical kramnik
move he doesn't care
how his moves look he only cares what
his moves
do and this is something we can all
learn from including myself
i tend to fall in love with moves that
kind of make a lot of noise
but look at kramnik's next move i want
you guys to find it
yup bishop f1 just drops his bishop back
and he defends e2 and he knows that the
bishop is not going to stay on f1
forever peace placement is dynamic
peace placement is temporary finally
i have to bring my bishop back i have
failed
if i go rook c6 which i think i
considered
i think and let me verify with the
computer full disclosure
um yes so rook c6 would have probably
been a better move sorry not h3
um and no actually bishop b7 is the best
i'll tell you guys later where exactly
my mistake was
the best move according to the computer
actually just is h3
uh and the queen is almost trapped i
think what i didn't like about this guys
is that my rook is now tied down to the
bishop right
and i just wanted to get rid of the
tension i wanted to say okay i'm gonna
give up a pawn
i don't care but at least my pieces are
a little bit more free okay
so i go rook c7 i'm actually playing all
computer moves this entire game
and i'll tell you guys where i falter he
drops his queen back now material is
equal i go rook a8
and basically what i got in return for
the pawn
at least my rook is active my bishop is
on the long diagonal my pieces are a
little bit stable
and finally my next move was a mistake i
had played perfectly up to this point
perfectly
my next move was a mistake
what should i have done i could have
actually kept equality
had i realized that black essentially
has only one big asset
in this position and this asset is the c
pot
and i need to push it as quickly as
possible and i did realize that but i
didn't push it in the right way
that is all it takes to lose to kramnik
is that kind of mistake i should have
gone bishop a6
and simply pushed this pawn for all that
it's worth c4 and c3 and the knight is
used
as a protector of the rook and as a
supporter of the c
pawn but i thought of it in a different
way
as you guys can probably understand i
wanted
the bishop to remain on b7 because i
wanted it to control the one diagonal i
thought that was important
so instead i went knight b6 and my idea
was exactly the same queen c1 c4 i
started to push the pawn
the problem here is twofold first of all
c3 is going to be harder to achieve
and second of all the problem is i
completely forgot
about the dark squares around my king
i just didn't realize that the knight
was doing a
incredibly good job at protecting some
of these squares and holding things
together
and all of a sudden now the floodgates
have opened and kramnik rushes in
with unbelievable vigor where does he go
and he returns back to a square from
which i had rudely kicked him out
now he comes back to this square this is
what makes this game absolutely
beautiful
bishop c3 is the right idea but there is
a better way of accomplishing it
what which is what we've seen that move
before
we've seen this move before not bishop
c3 bishop c3 maybe allows knight back to
d5 and i can pressure his bishop
bishop g5 bishop g5
now notice guys you're a lot of you are
suggesting bishop h6 but this is not a
good move
why because notice that the bishop on h6
is again i remember i told you don't
always make your queen do menial tasks
here
the queen is essentially tasked with
defending the bishop so the queen is not
going to have the mobility necessary
to maneuver let's say to a to f6 now you
might be saying but wait a second isn't
it the same situation here well it's not
really the same situation because the
queen can still come to f4
but the bishop has access to all of
these squares on this diagonal
i go queen g4 the reason i go queen g4
is because i was actually afraid of
of in addition to everything else the
idea of
h3 followed by g4 and my queen is
freaking trapped so i was like i need to
get my queen the hell out of there
now kramnik does absolute wizardry white
to play
and introduce even further strain in
black's position using this bishop not
only as a tool
to occupy squares but also as a tactical
weapon
exploiting my pieces being on the same
diagonal
boom look at this movement look at this
play
he's doing everything the bishop is a
hero in his hands it's attacking the
rook it's skewering the rook to the
knight
my move is forced i have to go rook c6
but wait a second look where the rook
has ended up do you guys see why this
could be a problem
not only am i blocking the bishop i'm
going under the ire of the bishop
and now kramnik goes h3 he chases my
queen away
and guess what he does now the bishop on
d2 has the bishop on d8 has done its job
if he goes bishop g2 and this is also
what makes kramnik so great he was
patient
if he goes bishop g2 that wouldn't be
good because i go knight d5
and i attack his bishop samith what's up
bishop back to g5 look at this bishop
back to g5 okay no problem i mean simply
okay you know he accumulates
and again he's threatening to trap my
queen and again he's straining my
position
forcing me to chase that bishop away
with roxy five
now the rook is in an even more
vulnerable square and finally kramnik
goes bishop f6 parks the bishop on this
diagonal
i go queen f5 again i have to chase it
away from there otherwise he's going to
lobster pincer mate me
he's going to lobster pincer made me
with the g4 actually the queen is
actually just trapped here
i mean and after he takes my queen he's
gonna lobster vincer made me
so i have to chase the bishop away guess
where the bishop now goes and this is
why he's forced my rook onto c5
now he can play with tempo what move
does he play
bishop d4 with tempo rook b5 i have to
slide my rook and keep the knight
protected
and here comes e4 attacking my queen
now what if i take the pawn in e4 why is
this why does this work what does
kramnik do here he had a
brilliant idea and it involves
of all pieces of the rook on a8 he takes
on b6
white to play and win material rook
takes c4
queen takes e4 bishop g2 pinning the
queen to the rook
i have to move my queen and he simply
takes the rook and he is up a piece
i mean can you believe this level of
tactical vision he notices
things that i would never notice in a
million years such as the rook on a8
playing a role
in this game now e4 looks like a
odd move because it allows queen f3 but
finally
the bishop which has sat on f1 so
patiently the entire game
returns to g2 and kicks the queen away
again
if i come to h5 with the queen again we
are familiar he goes g4 this is no good
i have to go around to a3 and now the
final three moves of the game are what's
going to get you off of your freaking
chairs
what's crazy about kramnik's play this
entire game is how flexible it's been
he's done all sorts of stuff
but now it's how quickly he redirects
his attention from the king side
to winning material one of the greatest
assets one of the greatest
strengths of gm's super gms like kramnik
is their ability to be doing something
for the entire game and whenever they
see a chance to win material
in the snap of a finger they change
their entire approach
queen h6 would be the tempting move but
it's not good because i can go e5 and i
can intercept
the bishop's control over the diagonal
but kramnik
takes in rook b1
and he wins a piece because look at my
knight on b6 and my bishop on b7
both of them are unprotected both of
them are under fire
i have to do something with this rook
and he's going to skewer me
if i go rook a5 to try to protect my
rook he simply takes the knight
and the rook x-ray defends the bishop i
took and i'm losing a piece i went c3
and now kramnik goes bishop takes b6
winning a knight
in this position i resigned uh out of
respect i
normally i would play longer but because
it's kramnik i resign it is completely
losing
and some of you may be like wait a
second don't i have this strong pot well
the pawn in and of itself
is not it's nothing right it's just
going to be easily picked up
uh the easiest plan for white is just to
bring the king over to d3 and take on c2
and he's going to be up a full piece
again against somebody else i would have
played this out for longer but against
kramnik i was
simply it had been an honor to play him
and he had
he deserved my resignation uh the
position is is simply losing
we analyzed we talked for five minutes
after the game
he explained some of his ideas and uh
this might have been the happiest i've
ever been after a loss i
normally don't take i mean who does take
losses well
this was a classical game guitar master
is open
uh this might have been the most uh just
high highest on life i've ever been in
russian and russia after a loss
because i had not only the privilege and
honor of playing him but he played one
of
i would say his greatest games against
me i mean he played like a 2900
and um this was incredible i think i
played out of my i played
my heart out i really made only one
mistake
my one mistake was was to move the
knight away from d5
i mean all of this was good this move
knight b6 what it did
was that it gave him too many of these
squares
yeah we analyzed in russian and then he
went to the press conference with
svidler he
talked about the game there i basically
incorporated
uh everything that he said there into my
analysis here you can take a look at it
you can youtube search it
and um that basically was my game
against kramnik i've also written a
chess.com article on my game against
kramer on this game
it's called anatomy of a brilliancy and
i analyze this game in great detail
and uh i don't want to like over hype
things but in my opinion
this was one of the few times when i
experienced firsthand
just absolute legendary play
and honestly uh this was i mean this was
just something to behold